But you've been doing it for so long that...
...obviously, people know you from this show as well as from work on NHK and the radio.
Oh, yeah!
What's the feedback you get from people on the street?
People like the show.
The people that know about it generally like it.
I don't think I've ever met anybody that watches the show and doesn't like it.
Well, a lot of people don't go out of their way to talk about shows they don't like...
That's true.
...to the entertainer who's on the show.
Although, I got a couple of... you tell him that...
I got a couple of... weeks ago, I got an e-mail written on to my blog, my Facebook page,...
...someone who wrote in says, "I watch your show all the time, you need to get a better stylist."
Well, thank you.
Actually, she didn't say better stylist. She said, "You need to get better clothes."
And I'm like, "I have someone getting those clothes for me, I'll pass on the information."
But yeah. Occasionally, people do give me pointers.
But, I mean, I've had basically nothing but praise about,...
...which is hardly surprising because it is just such good material.
I mean, the show has been running in America for over 40 years...
...and on prime time, a prime time on a Sunday evening.
So obviously, we've got to be doing something right.
It's the same slot as Sanma-no-karakuri-terebi, desune? Here in Japan.
Alright, okay. Yeah, okay. We're not gonna compete with that.
At least, we used to be on Sunday nights at half past 12 or something.
Oh, really? In America?
No, no. Oh, In America it's seven to eight on Sunday.
Exactly! So it's the same as Sanma-san here in Japan.
Yeah.